the character of Rick is a very
high-functioning alcoholic in Episode
three oh four we need to see him get
especially drunk so I encourage Justin -
2 method act first thing I told him was
don't have tequila and then of course he
had tequila and liquor just adds a whole
new aspect to Justin I understand things
get a little creative
how many shots is the right amount of
shots for drunk Rick this is my fourth
shot
I'm definitely probably going to be in
the pocket after this Wow
this little baby guy I'm gonna tell you
where to stick it
good because you got it see that sounds
you sober oh it doesn't sound great I
don't believe it
I know palladium 137 you're a bunch of
screaming demon that is me my lips are
chapped who's got chapstick here to
explain is a little bubble probe oh
thank you Christ what happens only die
what happens when we all died you guys
worry about that [ __ ] at night all right
forget it forget me I'm drunk [ __ ] I'm
gonna need another shot to do this oh
don't take it don't pay to be a thick
you turbo man wait like now halfway
through give me a quick wait old buddy
you know I get extra booze and I gotta
here kids hopefully whoever we elected
the next present
just allow my ability to get a gun and
kill myself what I think looks good
whines I've got three things I have to
do number one thing in my three list
thing is oh my god here to explain to
tell baby princess I've been working on
the shows in season 1 and this is by far
the least productive and messiest record
day we've ever had so what thanks a lot
Harmon oh can you hear it
it's a tiny violin oh did you have to
did you have to wrangle Justin for the
performance of a lifetime
everybody finally a little bit of new
Rick and Morty content behind the scenes
promo if you're wondering if he actually
drinks while he's in the booth he does
he's talked about drinking Hennessy it's
totally crazy but I guess it helps them
do the voices for Rick and Morty and
it's amazing to watch him actually do
the voices if you go to comic-con they
actually do live readings of scripts at
their panels like if they have animatics
to show up hey hey morning what do you
think of our moderator
I don't know Rick he seems like a real
flop sweaty sort of douchebag yeah I
know
I wish he'd uh throw to something a
cliff I don't know yeah me too
you know I'm sitting up here I came all
the way to comic-con it cost me a bunch
of money could find a hotel room or
nothing and I got to sit here and listen
to this [ __ ] who stresses something I
don't know what yeah I know more than
really embarrassing these dresses I
don't know is that up in Game of Thrones
reference yeah I don't know Rick but boy
I wish I sure wish he'd moved this thing
along in a way that would you know
entertain the crowd I could go on but I
won't point Mike point taken but he said
that sometimes his record sessions one
really long so by the end he is barely
standing and it'll be just completely
unintelligible stuff coming out of his
mouth I have absolutely no idea how he
gets any work done at all doing this if
you've ever seen someone try to record
lines like this the producers will like
shout stuff at them ideas and those who
spit them right back out try it this way
try it that way so they record way more
stuff than they actually ever send off
to be cut down for episodes so like
they'll record all day for a little bit
of material that'll get cut way down and
that'll make it to an episode then
they'll cut even more out and then it'll
be the stuff that you finally see in
episode I mean something about Justin
just the way he scammers and stutters
and Mitch speaks and says that very very
infectious in a way that a normal person
isn't you know you feel if you were
fringe when you hear a normal person not
be prepared and [ __ ] up and sometimes
Justin's version of just stumbling
through something
rising I guess very very like you know
case like candy in your mouth as long as
this is my opinion as long as you draw a
frame around it yes what's for sale here
is real sirs insanity but like Dan
Harmon's talking a little bit about
episode 304 here most of this actually
took place last year it's the actual
animation of episodes that's been taking
so long and the reason why you haven't
actually seen the rest of season 3 yet
besides that April Fool's Day episode 1
drop they haven't said anything about
when episode 2 is going to drop but they
are going to be re airing episode 1
periodically
I'm guessing hopefully by the end of
Samurai Jack that's supposed to air its
final episode May 20th so right now the
best theory is like the week after that
or sometime early June who knows I think
it just depends on how long it takes to
finish animating the last couple of
episodes because they can start airing
episodes as long as they have enough in
the can but I think the idea is for them
to air every episode without a break in
the middle just because they're so few
so you guys can let me know when do you
actually think that Rick and Morty is
going to drop do you think they'll wait
till after Samurai Jack or do you think
it'll be even longer in June because
they did say summer but that's a window
of a couple months so that's not that
specific at all but I will be doing more
episode videos as we get closer to the
season so be sure to subscribe to get
everything
leave all your requests for bonus videos
they haven't said what the episode
schedule is they might stream them on
Saturday nights like they do Samurai
Jack but typically in the past Rick and
Morty has been a Sunday night show so
we'll just see there should be a new
promo sometime relatively soon usually
when you start to see them dropping new
footage is when we get within about a
month or two of things actually
happening but while you wait for that
you can click here for all my Rick &
Morty videos and you can click here for
brand new flash thank you so much for
watching let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight
[Music]
[Applause]